wie weit ist eigentlich Afrika von uns
entfernt nicht weit wir haben ein
Afrikaner in der Schule und der kommt
jeden Morgen mit dem Fahrrad
und damit meine Damen und Herren darf
ich euch recht herzlich willkommen
heißen an einer weiteren Episode Luca
reagiert auf unlustige WhatsApp Chat
fails mit Luca das hatte ich schon am
Anfang drin habe letztens mit meiner
kleinen Schwester wer länger nicht sagt
gespielt hast du gewonnen nach 5 Minuten
fing sie an zu weinen ich was hast du
denn sie gewonnen
ich werde heute keiner Lachen wolltest
du immer schon einen 300.000 Euro Bands
fahren wenn nicht willst du 100 Frauen
am Tag mitnehmen klar damit wir Dich
heute noch als Busfahrer
der ist ca so alt wie meine Jobs ich
auch immer im Podcast reiße wo übrigens
auch eine neue Folge online ist
spotify.com/stick und Doof gerade ist
ein Polizist mit einem Polizeihund im
Auto gesessen was ist daran lustig kommt
ein kleiner Junge ist das ein Hund
Polizist ja wieso kleiner Junge
fassungslos warum haben sie den denn
verhaftet okay wow
über sowas sagt er will ich gar keinen
Humor ihr seid ja auf meinem
YouTube-Kanal also ihr müsst glaube ich
auch alle keine Humor haben meine
Schwester es ist mit einer Schwester sie
weißt du was lecker wäre wenn es ein
Smoothies geben würde dann könnte man
die so essen
Gentleman meine Schwester hat gerade den
Obstsalat erfunden
bist du vorhin eigentlich hingefallen
nein den Boden umarmt das ist aber
wirklich auch so eine dumme Frage ne
so auch wenn man irgendwie sich den Kopf
stößt oder man fällt hin oder beim Sport
kriegt man ein Ball irgendwo gegen in
die Eier oder was weiß ich was und dann
Leute fragen
nee Brot hat richtig gut so hä du Lauch
dann sind wir ja der perfekte
Flammkuchen warum das Lauch und Speck
das hätte tatsächlich ein guter Podcast
Name sein können
wir haben uns schon oft die Frage
gestellt wenn wir uns nicht dick und
Doof genannt hätten wir uns dann
vielleicht hätten nennen können und
Lauch und Speck wäre auf jeden Fall gut
oder halt Flammkuchen einfach weil dann
wird unser Podcast Flammkuchen heißt und
Leute die es wüssten dann halt dass wir
wegen laufen Speck Flammkuchen heißen
aber an sich auch ein geiler Name wäre
Lauch und Bauch
das haben wir uns auch mal überlegt dass
wir auch richtig krass schreib mir mal
gerne unten in die Kommentare wie du
unseren Podcast genannt hättest absolut
ich brauche dringend deine hilfe was
gibt's beantworte mir das wenn ich eine
Voodoo Puppe von mir selbst mache und
mich drauf lege kann ich dann nie wieder
aufstehen
wie high bist du
also
so dumm ist die Frage eigentlich nicht
klar also ich glaube jetzt nicht in
diesen ganzen Voodoo Krams und so
generell auch das ganze mit Kartenlegen
und so
jetzt wirklich Leute die dann so sagen
die Karte hat jetzt gerade vorher gesagt
dass ich morgen irgendwie keine Ahnung
ich fahre jetzt besser nicht Auto oder
so menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
benutzt du eigentlich diesen emoji und
dann halt so eine Regen emoji und die
Person antwortet deine dummen Fragen
regen mich echt auf
der war nicht schlecht
aber auch nicht gut Trick 17 auf der
Couch entspannen mein Freund steht auf
weil sein Handy auf dem Küchentisch
klingelt es ist eine Nachricht von mir
wenn du schon stehst kannst du mir
gleich auch noch die Chips mitbringen
das ist richtig gut
das ist richtig gut das Problem ist
allerdings dass man meistens auf der
Couch stellt mit seinem Kollegen
dass man dann halt auch sein Handy bei
sich hat nehmt ihr wenn ihr zum Beispiel
duschen geht oder generell ins Bad geht
auf Toilette etc pp nehmt ihr euer Handy
mit oder dass sie es liegen
weil no joke alle Leute die ich kenne
neben ihr Handy mit außer ein Kollege
von mir
Sirio
einen wunderschönen guten Tag und
herzlich willkommen
ähm warum ich mein Handy nicht mitnehme
auf die Toilette kann ich Dir ganz kurz
erklären und zwar
würde dann würde ich auch tiktok sein
Twitch ich würde dann irgendwie keine
Ahnung irgendwelche Sachen machen
die nicht zum
Stuhlgang gehören
Toilette machen
[Musik]
eigentlich
was hast du heute für eine Yogaübung
gemacht Kerze du hast dabei gefurzt
Duftkerze
es immer gleich ne
ich lese das hier vor dann lasse ich es
kurz Revue passieren atme tief ein und
denkt mir kommen Luca regt den hier auf
gibt genug leider auf der Welt die
WhatsApp Welt die versauen manchmal
wünsche ich mir dass etwas zwischen uns
wäre ich auch echt und das wäre eine
Wand
ich weiß jetzt warum ich immer so viel
esse wenn ich gestresst bin und wieso
stressed heißt rückwärts Desserts
oh mein Gott
das könnten oh Jones neuer WhatsApp
Status werden online Portal ihr Passwort
muss 225 Zeichen lang sein klein und
Großbuchstaben Sonderzeichen und
natürlich das Haar eines Alpakas
enthalten Bank hier vier Zahlen die
Schützen dein Vermögen oh mein Gott ich
mache jetzt eine Instagram Story das ist
im Digger mir ist das noch nie
aufgefallen gestern habe ich einen Club
angesprochen erzählt ich Doppelpunkt du
bist mir direkt aufgefallen weil du hier
als einzige keinen Ausschnitt bis zum
Bauchnabel trägst sie Doppelpunkt wozu
den Kühlschrank öffnen wenn keine
Melonen drin sind
sie spielt zumindest direkt mit offenen
Karten gerade hat im Supermarkt so ein
Opa die Einkaufskörbe blockiert und ich
Doppelpunkt können Sie mir bitte einen
Korb geben Opi Doppelpunkt ich weiß
nicht gewöhnlich gebe ich schon Frauen
keine Körbe der ist richtig stark
der ist richtig stark oh mein Gott wenn
ich im Supermarkt arbeiten würde dann
würde ich mal fünf Mal beten aber ganz
schnell ich musste gerade am Bahnsteig
so lachen warum eine Schulklasse ist am
Bahnsteig Durchsage zurückbleiben bitte
Lehrer zurückgeblieben seid ihr ja schon
aber geht trotzdem mal von der Dürre Weg
alles klar
Lehrer sind generell einfach Arschlöcher
ne
also wirklich ich kann an einer anderen
abzählen von allen boah keine Ahnung 40
Lehrer mit denen ich in meinem ganzen
Leben bisher zu tun hatte wer wirklich
korrekt war
warum haben warum sind so viele Lehrer
so verbittert ich höre mit dem Saufen
auf gestern habe ich meine Frau doppelt
gesehen wenn ich deine Frau doppelt
sehen würde würde ich mit dem Saufen
anfangen
das sind so richtige
wisst ihr was den schicke ich jetzt
meinem Vater und ich weiß ganz genau
dass er diesen Joke in seine
stammtischgruppe weiterleiten wird hast
du Zeit ja klar was ist denn los also
ich habe eine gute und eine schlechte
Nachricht für dich welche zuerst egal
leg los also ich möchte nicht mehr mit
dir zusammen sein okay und was ist die
schlechte Nachricht ah
chillig Bro habe heute eigentlich nie
Witz erzählt und keine Reaktion
okay
gebe ich weiter
2014 hat angerufen die wollen ihre Witze
zurück in vorhin mit dem Postboten
zusammengestoßen
nee DHL